let's turn to other world news now and
members of a political Alliance of 13
parties in Pakistan are protesting
outside the Supreme Court to demand the
resignation of the Chief Justice they
say former prime minister Imran Khan has
been treated leniently by the courts
last week Khan was granted two weeks
bail after being arrested on corruption
charges let's go live to Al jazeera's
Kamal Haider who's outside the Supreme
Court in Islamabad come out bring us up
to speed first with what's been
happening outside the court there
yeah
well as you mentioned the 13 party
Airlines which is the government in
power had announced that they will be
staging a major sitting outside the
Supreme Court today the government is
quite critical of the Supreme Court
they've been criticizing senior judges
of the court now this is spearheaded by
Mr father Rahman he's the head of the
Jamaica
Islam he himself has not been able to
win a single seat uh his own seat that
is his son is still in Parliament and of
course the judicial Community or the
rather the legal fraternity has said
that this is Unthinkable that the
sitting government is protesting against
the Supreme Court now it is the same
Supreme Court that was praised by Mr
father Rahman when there was a ward of
no confidence the Supreme Court stepped
in and made sure that vote of no
confidence wins went ahead which led to
the 13 party in lines forming the new
government so indeed a tense situation
because it is expected that the Supreme
Court is likely to hold the Prime
Minister and senior members of the
cabinet on contempt charges that is what
is being said here in Pakistan the legal
fraternity of course is saying that this
is a total violation of the constitution
for the parliamentarians and the
political leaders to single out their
country's Apex court for criticism
meanwhile Kamal I understand the
Crackdown against Imran Khan's
supporters continues
absolutely in fact the government has
been arresting all the key leaders
they've been breaking into their houses
smashing the door did a report that the
families have been manhandled most of
the Pakistan telekines of leadership is
now Behind Bars they of course have been
arrested and on the pretext of public
maintenance order this is a clause under
which they can arrest anybody from 15 to
30 days so the senior leadership
arrested many peaceful protesters who
have been taking part in the protest
against the government have also been
arrested sweeping operations are
underway and of course the government is
now trying to put the owners of blame on
Imran Khan for all the violence that
took place when he was arrested he of
course has said that he was in jail and
had no control over those crowds who
went on the Rampage so indeed that the
government hell-bent on trying to Corner
Imran Khan's party all the leadership is
under arrest and they of course are
trying to disqualify him to make him a
relevant however his popularity
continues to grow and that of course is
going to be a main challenge for this 30
13 party Airlines which is now seen in
defiance of the country's Apex Court
okay come on thank you very much for
that update Kamal Haider live force in
Islamabad